hey guys this is Pete peppers with the
candy crush soda saga level 189
commentary walkthrough and add some tips
to it it's it's kind of a hard level
though where the there's really not
really not a trick to it or there's
really much not much other than a couple
simple tips that you can do them and
just hang in there to get the right
board so that what I'm doing in the
beginning here is trying to find out
where the Bears are so I found one at
the top and it looks like the one at the
bottom is there too so you want to take
off one layer around the ice so that you
can see if there's you know that blue
color like here you can see that um I
just found one that's in the top left so
I can see two of them now so I just want
to find out what the other where the
other one is and if I get chances so
there's not one there but your chances
are like fire ups striped candies or
something into those lanes like I'm
gonna get right here then you know I'll
go ahead and do that
and I just missed a little bit fast
there I just missed a color bomb that
would have set up with this fish but
we'll see what can happen and we'll see
what we can still get through it it's
always so always a bad feeling so
there's no bearer there
fish you know the fish don't really do a
lot here by themselves but they can be
good when you can match them with
straight candies especially you like
well either way is good but um like when
we're still trying to figure out where
the Bears are at and stuff so we can if
we can match them with a horizontal
stripe they're gonna go across the whole
the whole group and so that can be
really useful like right here you can go
ahead and match this and that all um
yeah so now we know where they all are
we got one here too on the top corners
one on the bottom corner and then one
second from the right so you know what
21 moves it feels like that should be
pretty easy but this levels the reason
why this levels so frustrating is
because it's not you can see that the
dark the dark blue candies are out too
so like all seven colors are on the
board
which just means it's really hard to
make matches and um even though we know
where all the Bears are and then we
still have 20 moves like that's
definitely possible that we might not
make it and we got lucky there the fish
actually went somewhere good I mean
that's gonna happen some of the times
and then we set up a chance for that to
happen so now we just sort of want to
like try to focus on this side of the
board you know you want to scan to see
if there's stuff happening and you can
also do this like where you you know
take out ice other places because
there's a higher probability that the
the fish is gonna go where you want to
but well they go that's so that worked
out there but um so we got the board we
needed like it like it said there wasn't
a whole lot as far as like really solid
tips just in the beginning the first
thing you want to do is find out well
where all four bears are and then from
there you just want to focus on those
columns and you know it's hard to do
because all the extra colors are out
but look for stripes horizontals and
match them with fish or you can match
two types together without a clear call
them stuff like that and just hang in
there it could take a quite a few tries
but if you keep going at it and you get
those bears and know where they're at
then you'll eventually get it just like
I did so I hope this helps please like
the video surprised subscribe to our
channel to support us and so you'll find
out when you get new videos like this
and we'll be seeing you soon thanks